okay you guys nothing says the holiday
like some home cooking and some holiday
movies and guess what
our next guest is actually gonna bring
us both of those wonderful things please
take a look at her new movie blending
christmas
well i took the liberty of printing out
some of the lyrics
not that i think you guys need them but
old lang's eye
yeah what about it it's not a christmas
song
of course it is it's an old scottish
folk song it has nothing to do with
christmas except for that it's sung at
christmas time
it's sung at new year's okay we can
worry about that later
oh i know
please welcome
thank you for having me you look excited
so gorgeous so do you i was looking at
your hair i was like i like your hair
girl we were just talking i was like
you're inspiring me to want to go get
some beachy highlights and i was
watching you backstage and i was like
her hair is darker and i love it it
looks great thank you um i'm so excited
about this movie thank you
please tell me about it uh blending
christmas is like just a really great
feel-good lifetime christmas movie it's
all the things you sort of expect with
these christmas stories of like love and
family and this one happens to have like
a really crazy
family and we're blending our families
at christmas time and the family also is
very exciting because it's the brady
bunch
which is like doesn't everyone want
their family to be the brady bunny it's
like
greg
it's the actual brady bunch
and they play all the aunts and uncles
and it they're so cute together they're
so hilarious
it was really sweet i mean how fun is
this because that really was like all of
our childhood fantasies was to live in
the brady bunch totally and i have two
girls and you have two yes i know
actually i know
i have to tell you i love being a girl
mom i loved that i got sisters like i
grew up with a sister and i'm like you
know i'm partial to the sister stuff and
you're i mean everybody loves your
sister
hello she's really been here to see you
has she been here no oh
no
she's going to come through that has
come here but i would love to see your
sister yeah um i think that was for me
like the most exciting thing about
finding out i was having another girl so
i was like i loved being a sister and
then now i have sisters and people used
to say to me like are you gonna try for
that boy and i was like no we're not
we're good
yeah i love the sister
family i'm like it's good and i get to
like spoil my nephew lucas the boy of
our family so that's hillary's son yes
yeah he's uh and she's so wonderful she
has three that's amazing she got a set
of sisters now too oh good oh sisters
and mothers and daughters and all that
it is it's my journey in life um
something else that i am a big fan of
though is eating food yes cooking
and i'm really excited because you have
this awesome cooking show real girls
kitchen thank you and so you're going to
teach us some stuff today yes and you
know what's fun about blending christmas
too is there's a cooking scene in it so
i actually got to like they call it
stress baking in the movie and when she
gets stressed out by her family and this
like bad proposal that's happening um
she stress bakes which is kind of
similar to what i do in real life i'm
like
you've heard the expression like eat
your feelings
it's what i do all the time
in fact i did it last night
but i usually stress not stress bake i
stress take out and
oh i think there's a story where the
i know this show was brought on by
something about takeout menus yes well
so you're talking about when my mom
discovered my takeout menu drawer and
that prompted this show it really did it
prompted me to learn how to cook because
i moved into my first house and i had
this beautiful kitchen
and i didn't know how to feed myself my
mom's a great cook my dad's a great cook
and so i never
had to cook anything they were always
like
you know yeah look at all that and look
how far i've come so guess what the
student speaks
okay so
today we're going to make one of my
favorite holiday recipes mainly because
i feel like we really indulge a lot in
the holidays
hence the burrata under all that i'll
take it over there i love it i love a
salmon
during the holidays it's like a little
unexpected so this is a really really
easy recipe you're basically going to
take your little whisk here this is um
some honey some dijon mustard a couple
little spices in there and you're just
going to mix it all up i love it what
it's going to do in the airfryer is it's
going to kind of like caramelize and
make it a little thicker so it's going
to stay in place versus like running off
of the salmon
so we'll take our salmon and we'll just
put it right in there
and it's gonna coat all over it if you
want to get real crazy you can leave it
in like a marinade but you really don't
have to
the trick with the salmon is parchment
paper and it's one thing i really love
to use with this recipe because have you
ever cooked salmon and then the skin
comes off on the pan and you're like oh
this looks like a mess
the parchment paper will save your skin
and you'll get that beautiful like
crispy skin on the bottom which also
makes it easier when you're serving it
to everybody so preheating your air
fryer a couple minutes this is nice and
warm now
we're gonna take it out okay so this is
gonna just lay right into the bottom
and then you're gonna just put your
salmon on top skin side down
and i do like to keep a little of the
sauce on the side that has not been
contaminated with your raw salmon so
afterwards you can add some extra sauce
if you like things a little bit saucy
and put that in
and depending on the size of your salmon
like six to seven minutes don't you
don't want to go too crazy because then
it'll be really dry
um so we've got about five minutes on
there and that's probably gonna be so
tell me about this quiche because i'm
not gonna lie it's it's amazing honestly
i'm so excited about this quiche tell me
about it okay so so i can help
she's like boom boom boom just right in
um
this is one thing that i love during the
holidays because you can make like an
arugula salad to go with it and it can
be a whole meal
um but yeah i just love this one it has
all different kinds of mushrooms in it
[Music]
i know this is like the display quiche
but i don't care get it girl
i'm like how did i do it is one of my
very favorite foods too oh good
and it's like pretty easy to make is it
good it's like that
there's a parmesan
pecorino situation going on in there too
that's pretty deadly it's very classical
you know it gives you that really
wonderful french mushroom delicious i'm
just gonna try yeah there's like
creminis in there there's all different
kinds
and then the recipe you guys can find
andrew's
[Applause]
the
website
now this beautiful crostini plate yes
and this is how somebody eats brussels
sprouts
so my my husband when we first started
dating would not eat anything green he's
like a steak and potatoes
like not a green juice nothing
and so i started making that crazy i was
like how do you survive that long with
like not a vegetable and he's very
healthy it makes no sense
so i started making brussels sprouts um
but i started making them with bacon and
then of course as you guys know
everything with bacon is better so it
really really is
that all of a sudden a vegetable is like
amped up
and then here we have the tv magic the
beautiful
yes salmon
or it looks so good why breaks residents
now this is scary
just give us the big one girl just give
us the display salmon
it's really beautiful and i can't say
i've never seen a honey mustard with the
real honey it usually just comes already
done like pre-mixed yes well so for me i
love the mouth feel of those little
grainy bits from like the whole grain
mustard it kind of has like the little
bite to it and honey food is really one
of my very favorite combinations honey
anytime is like exactly yeah oh
this is so fun i loved cooking with you
so happy to do this with you can we do
this again yes anytime you tell me thank
you to haley doug try haley's recipes to
visit our website at the dreamweaver.com
and make sure to see blending christmas
and it premieres december 12th at 8pm
eastern 7 pm central on lifetime
[Music]
you